Любые отношения во внешнем мире — это точно такая же декорация, точно такой же сценарий, как и с реализацией, как и с деньгами, как и с любой другой сферой, которые рождаются из вас как из источника и обслуживают ваше состояние, ваше знание, у мире, о людях, об отношениях, о мужчинах, о себе, в контексте отношений и так далее.
То есть любые отношения рождаются из вас, потому что это сценарий, а все сценарии рождаете вы.
Что это для нас значит?
Это говорит о том, что вы можете создать любые отношения, любого партнера, любой формат отношений, который вам захочется и так далее.
То, что вы сейчас в данный конкретный период жизни наблюдаете в своей реальности, в сфере и контексте отношений — это идеальное отражение в ваших же собственных формочек сознания, то есть ваше представление, ваше знание об этой сфере, которые отражаются именно вот так.
Они вот так вот отразились в реальности и проявились согласно тому, что есть у вас внутри.
Вы можете сейчас поставить на паузу и ответить на следующие вопросы, я рекомендую письменно, либо надиктовать себе.
Сейчас я буду вам перечислять, и вы вместе со мной прописываете, отвечаете на этот вопрос, на эти вопросы точнее, либо поставьте потом на паузу чуть попозже, когда я все сейчас перечислю, что нужно сделать, и надиктуйте.
Как вам комфортно?
Еще важно, я сказала, что отношения в реальности в физическом мире, они отражают то, что есть у вас внутри.
То, что есть у вас внутри — это незафиксированная субстанция, важно.
Это просто то, во что вы направили момент, в какой-то момент.
Ой, направили момент. Короче, это то, во что вы направили внимание в какой-то момент своей жизни. Осознан или нет.
Если вас удивляет сфера отношений в вашей жизни, скажем так, это значит, что есть что-то, на что вы не осознанно направляете внимание, какие-то знания в отношениях о людях, о мужчинах, о женщинах и так далее.
И это идеальным образом проецируется в реальность, потому что, как мы помним, реальность — это уже следствие, это просто тень.
Любые отношения в вашей реальности — это просто как фильм, который высвечивается с проектора на стену, и он там идет.
Проектор — это вы как источника, который рождает из себя эти отношения.
Так вот, вернемся к нашей практике небольшой, к заданию. Напишите или надиктуйте, что такое отношение.
Я рекомендую выбрать группу людей, с которыми вы хотите сейчас поглубже разобрать отношения.
Это могут быть мужчины или подруги, другие женщины, работодатели, возможно, клиенты.
В общем, то, где у вас запрос, возможно, это дети. В общем, возьмите эту сферу и ответьте на следующий вопрос.
Вот это группа людей. Какая это группа людей?
Итак, вопрос номер один. Отношение — это что такое?
То есть, что вообще такое отношение? Что вы знаете об отношениях в контексте группы, которую вы выбрали?
Например, что вы знаете об отношениях между мужчиной и женщиной? Отношения я между мужчиной и женщиной — они чаще всего какие?
Чаще всего — как они складываются? Чаще всего — что в них происходит? И что им характерно?
Вот выписываете либо надиктовываете? Вот честно и искренне ни на показ, это останется только между вами и листочком, либо диктофоном.
Войцем и так далее. В общем, куда-то выложите из себя все, что вы знаете об отношениях с мужчинами или с подругами.
Например, вот женская дружба — это что? Дружба между женщиной и женщиной — она бывает или нет?
Если да, то что там обычно происходит? Что характерно для женской дружбы?
Вот все эти вопросы вам нужно дать на них ответы.
И рекомендую делать это прямо сейчас вместе со мной в формате такой практики. Небольшой.
Вот отношения с работодателями, отношения с клиентами, клиенты — они какие? Родители — они какие? Дети — они какие?
Первый вопрос — это что вы знаете конкретно об отношениях с группой людей, с мужчинами, с подругами, с другими женщинами? Неважно.
В общем, что вы знаете об отношениях с мужчинами или с другой группой людей? Поставьте на паузу и выложите это куда-то.
Второй вопрос — это что вы знаете конкретно об этой группе, с которой вы хотите побольше разобрать отношения с этой группой людей?
Например, что вы знаете о мужчинах, если у вас сейчас интересно, вам сейчас интересно разобраться в этой теме.
Что вы знаете о мужчинах? Мужчины — это вообще кто? Мужчины — они какие? Чаще всего. Как они обычно проявляются?
Вообще, вот, просто собирательный образ мужчины. Он у вас какой в вашей голове? Кто такой мужчина? Как он проявляется обычно? Как он не проявляется?
Я попрошу вас описывать честно. Маркером будет знать, что ваша реальность, потому что реальность отражает ваши знания.
Если у вас знание о мужчина — это такой невероятный человек, он готов сделать все для женщины, а в реальности у вас какие-то идиоты, значит, где-то вы себе врете.
То есть пишите честно то, что вы думаете. Вот искренне представьте, что вы с подругой сейчас сидите на кофе и обсуждаете.
Вот тоже как еще можно из себя вытащить знания и по-честному, чтобы это было искренне.
Это вспомнить свои, возможно, предыдущие недавние разговоры с людьми на эту тему.
Что вы в последний раз обсуждали со своей подругой, со своими подругами, допустим, насчет мужчин? Какие они эти мужчины?
Что они делали, как они проявлялись и так далее? Вот это вот чистая правда будет.
Или что вы в последний раз говорили кому-то про эту группу людей, про подруг, про мужчин, про работодателей.
То есть ваши вот эти вот все разговоры, диалоги, это уже следствие вашей внутренних знаний.
Сейчас я попрошу вас сделать то же самое, но опять же, с ремарочкой, с пометочкой, чтобы это было честно.
Пишите прямо, реально, что вы думаете про подруг, про женскую дружбу, про мужчин, что вы думаете, кто это вообще за персонажа.
Честно пишем. Как понять, что вы честно пишете особого разделения и несоответствия между вашими знаниями и реальностью? Нет.
Потому что ваша дитя куча реальность, просто проекция, такая тень, которая вот отражается об эти знания.
Вот, дальше вопрос номер три. Это кто вы внутри этих отношений с этими людьми?
Кто вы в контакте с этими людьми? Допустим, какая вы подруга? Какой вы друг, если у вас группа людей это подруги, отношения с женщинами?
Либо какая вы в глазах мужчин? Какая вы внутри отношений в этой сфере? Как вас воспринимают мужчины, как вы думаете, ваши знания выкладываете?
Как вас воспринимают женщины, девушки, другие подруги? Как вас воспринимают коллеги на работе, если вы хотите в эту тему углубиться?
Как вас воспринимают работодатели, клиенты, родители, дети? В смысле, сколько группы вы опять же сейчас взаимодействуете?
Выписывайте вот этот объект.
По поводу серьезных отношений, если вам это актуально и вам интересен этот опыт, выписывайте, что вы знаете, что вы думаете насчет серьезных отношений.
Могут ли отношения существовать долго? Могут ли они существовать долго без серьезных проблем в отношениях?
Или отношения — это какой-то труд, где нужно постоянно преодолевать препятствия.
И вообще, если пару, 10 лет в браке, то обязательно измены. Или у вас вообще другие знания, либо у вас хорошие знания, именно в контексте создания долгосрочных отношений.
Опять же, хорошая отоценка ума, да, но с точки зрения создания того, чего вы хотите, я имею в виду.
В общем, выписывайте все, что вы знаете насчет серьезных отношений.
Все вот эти вот знания и представления зафиксируйте где-нибудь, пусть они у вас будут.
И последнее — это ваше искреннее отношение к себе.
Вот здесь, конечно, такой вопросик немножко со звездочкой, потому что очень часто мы не отслеживаем эти процессы отношения к себе,
потому что это неосознанное чаще всего, автоматические действия, которые мы к себе направляем.
Поэтому здесь я даю вам задание такое, на перспективу, отслеживать ваше искреннее отношение с собой.
Туда входит, как вы с собой общаетесь, дура ты, что опять проспала, жирная свинья опять и пожиралась, или ничего страшного, мы с тобой справимся.
У тебя все получится, я тебя люблю и в тебе верю.
Разные диалоги, вот вы как с собой общаетесь?
Опять же, здесь вы можете, конечно, в моменте ответить, но если вы до этого не отслеживали и таким вопросом не задавались,
то даю вам задание на перспективу, возьмите один день, либо два дня, неделю, проследите, можете себе таймеры поставить, напоминания,
можете просто сами как-то вот отслеживать, как вы с собой общаетесь внутри себя.
Второе, это, естественно, как вы к себе относитесь.
Думаете ли вы о себе в первую очередь, или сначала другие, потом себе?
Сначала я дам все детям, потом себе, я потерплю, я подожду.
Сначала я дам все мужу, потом себе.
Сначала сделаю для родителей, потом себе, то есть себе как будто крохи отдаёте.
Да, здесь честно, отслеживайте, опять же, вход в трансформацию происходит через честность, потому что пока мы запихиваем говно под ковёр,
говно воняет, но мы его не видим, нам непонятно, что здесь менять,
а когда мы говно реально видим в глаза, мы можем его убрать, ну, условно, да?
Вот, поэтому выписываем, либо фиксируем в перспективе, смотрим хотя бы неделю, день-два, как вам комфортно.
Либо сейчас вы можете уже, может быть, какие-то выводы сделаетесь в последних событиях и последние ваши отношения к себе и так далее,
как вы проявлялись к себе, может быть, вы уже отслеживали, в общем, то, как вы к себе относитесь.
Вот это все зафиксируйте где-нибудь на бумаге, либо на диктофоне.
И еще, кстати, по поводу отношения к себе, как еще разosoold 갈еть отношение к себе?
Посмотреть на отношения вас к другим и других к вам.
Еще раз, отношения вас к другим, отношения других к вам.
Потому что отношение вас к другим, это идеальное отражение отношения вас к себе.
Если вы действуете даже не действия сами, да, а состояние, из которого вы действуете.
действуйте и аналогично отношения других к вам это уже зеркало отношения вас к себе
вот поэтому вы можете по этому очень тоже точно отследить вот эти паттерны которые у вас реально есть это будет как раз такие
безобманно потому что если можно обмануть себя что я себе люблю то реальность
уже невозможно обмануть да если вы частно посмотрите на реальность например что люди вас поставят на последнее место
мужчины например они про вас забывают они там как такого относится определенным образом но вы такие выписывайте я себя обожаю
я себя очень люблю если я вставлю на первое место но в реальность у вас другой вообще фидбэк это говорит о том что вы все тут немножко вретим либо
либо не немножко в общем смотрите на три стези в контексте отношения к себе отношения к себе дали отношения вас к другим то есть
если у вас агрессия к другим например если у вас зависть такая вы знаете черная плохая что лишь бы у тебя этого не было
ах блин у тебя получилось лучше бы тебе не получилось если у вас наоборот может быть любовь к другим искренне щедрость вот вы хотите отдавать
делиться изнутри себя то есть что у вас к другим вообще направлено и далее что от других направлено к вам
смотрим ваши близкие круг людей подруги партнеры ухажеры и так далее
теперь вот все что вы выписали в качестве того что вы знаете об отношениях о себе в контексте отношений и далее
по списочку которую я вам продиктовала вот это все является техническим заданием сырьем из которого ткется ваша
реальность в контексте отношений то есть это точно такие же знания и представления с которыми вы как энергия
бесконечно феечная абсолютно отождествили себя и реальность начала это зеркалить здесь то же самое
нужно разочувствовать с этими формочками осознав что это не ваш что это не вы в это не выбирали осознанно
почему вообще у вас это должно быть не осознанно перевыбрать другие формочки как бы себя вела и ощущала
та версия вас которая желанна для других людей во всех контекстах и для подруг и для мужчин и
так далее и как бы она себя чувствовала как бы она себя вела как бы она себя ощущала сама
ощущала вот с этим вы теперь отожставляетесь то есть с теми формой мирад caught а же снимайте это не
вы точно так же как формочки на счет вашей идентичности здесь аналогично и отождеств propriet с тем что
вам интересно что вы мне интересно прыгать чтоб интересно теперь познать потому что вы являетесь
просто абсолютной вечностью и отожитая себя с чем-то реально начинает это отражать.
Меняете то, с чем вы себя отожистили, меняется в ответ реальность.